but unfortunately we have these cases
when it really happens and because of
that our soldier die and right now uh
when I when I was traveling around the
front line I was talking to soldiers and
they were telling me that um
brigades uh have not enough people to
fight in so because volunteers ended and
um the conscription is going on but it
is not enough and Ukraine is losing lot
of people and it has less people than
Russia so every life matters not because
just only every life matters but because
Ukraine doesn't have many people to
fight and we don't know how long this
war is going to last for and if we have
the opportunity to help the injured
soldiers and later if the injury is not
so heavy they can come back to the front
line we should do it